- She had a part time job
and didn't have enough money
to support her young children,
so she had turned at
times to prostitution.
And he had sent food down through Caritas,
you know, Catholic charity organization,
to feed the kids and the woman.
And she came around
Christmas and asked for him.
he came down and said,
"Oh, I glad you got the food."
And she said, "Well
thank you for the food,
"but I really wanted to thank you
"because you always called me Senora."
And, um--
- [Woman] The respect.
- It's respect and it's like
seeing into that person's soul
and figuring out that
what they really needed
was the food, of course.
But what they really, really needed was
to be treated with respect
and to be treated as a human being.
You know, it's these little
gestures that he does
when he invites homeless
people to the Vatican
for his birthday.
When he goes and visits prisoners.
When he comes to America
and he gets in a Fiat,
and all the big leadership
in America gets in those--
- I love that.
- huge SUVs,
and a 78 year-old man
gets in the back seat
of a little Fiat?
I mean, he's sending a message to us.
And I think that's a huge challenge.